D
CHILDREN GUNNED DOWN BY AN
18-YEAR-OLD WHO THEN WAS TAKEN
DOWN BY AUTHORITIES.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL, HAROLD
FORD JR. FORMER TENNESSEE
CONGRESSMAN, CO-HOST OF "THE THD
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY ARI FLEISCHER.
ARI, YOU DEALT WITH, YOU KNOW, A
NUMBER OF THESE KINDS OF EVENTS
AND SHOOTINGS DURING YOUR TIME
AS WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY.
WE HAVE SEEN THEM INCREASE OVER
THE YEARS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS DAY AND
WHERE WE GO FROM HERE.
>> WELL, THE IMMEDIATE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS THE
COMPASSION AND THE SUPPORT THAT
NEEDS TO BE EXTENDED TO THE
FAMILIES AND EVERYBODY AT THE
SCHOOL.
EVEN THOSE WHO DIDN'T LOSE THEIR
CHILDREN.
THEY ARE TRAUMATIZED.
AND THAT COMMUNITY IS GOING TO
COME TOGETHER AND THEY NEED THE
HELP FROM EVERYBODY AND LOVE
FROM EVERYBODY.
BEYOND THAT IT'S SUCH A FEELING
OF HOPELESSNESS, ISN'T IT?
I DON'T LIVE VERY FAR FROM
NEWTOWN, CONNECTICUT WHERE THAT
KILLING TOOK PLACE AND IT
CHANGED ALL THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS IN THE AREA WHERE I AM
FROM.
YOU CAN'T EVEN GET INTO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS UP HERE
ANYMORE.
THERE ARE DOUBLE DOORS.
THEY ARE LOCKED.
IF YOU WALK IN THAT FIRST DOOR
YOU CAN'T GET THROUGH THE SECOND
DOOR.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HARDEN
OUR ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE DECADES.
AND I'M AFRAID THAT IS THE ONLY
PRACTICAL THING I CAN THINK OF.
EVERYTHING ELSE WILL GET LOST IN
THE POLITICS AND THE BLAME GAME.
>> Bret: YES, WHICH WHICH IS SAD
IN AND OF ITSELF.
HAROLD, YOUR THOUGHTS.
YOU HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN.
AND ON THIS DAY, THE PARENTS
RECEIVING A NEWS IS THE THING
THAT EVERYBODY JUST THINKS ABOUT
WHAT IF IT WAS ME?
>> BRET, THANKS AND ARI, I AGREE
WITH YOU WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
MY KIDS WERE COMING IN THE DOOR
FROM SPORTS AS THE STORY WAS
UNFOLDING.
AS I WAS BEGINNING TO SEE IT
UNFOLD ON TELEVISION.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE EVERY PARENT.
MY KIDS ARE 7 AND 8, ANY PARENT
WITH ANY AGE CHILD, YOUNG CHILD
IS GOING TO HUG EVEN AND HUG AND
LOVE EVEN HARDER AND CLOSER THIS
EVENING.
I THINK ARI IS RIGHT ABOUT WHAT
WE HAVE TO DO IN SCHOOLS.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS PUBLIC
OFFICIALS HAVE TO BE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR THOSE ELECTED TO
PUBLIC OFFICE HAVE TO PONDER AT
THIS MOMENT IS WHAT CAN BE DONE
DIFFERENTLY AND WHAT CAN BE DONE
AS FAST AS POSSIBLE?
FIRST, WE NEED TO GET TO THE
ABOUT THE OF WHAT HAPPENED HERE
IN THIS SITUATION.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY I PRAY FOR THOSE
FAMILIES.
I HOPE THESE NUMBERS DO NOT GO
UP.
THE DEATH TOLL NUMBERS.
BUT AS BILL MELUGIN AND OTHERS
WHO IN HIS GREAT REPORTING
EARLIER, WHAT WE LEARNED IS THAT
THE NUMBERS MAY GO UP.
AND EVEN TRACE GALLAGHER AS HE
COVERED THIS EARLIER.
SCHOOLS AND STREETS, SUBWAYS,
PUBLIC PLACES LIKE GROCERY
STORES, I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
WILLING TO CONFRONT THE
CONVERSATION AROUND GUNS.
AND FIGURE OUT THERE ARE
SENSIBLE THINGS WE CAN DO.
HARD CHARGE AND HIGHLY
POLITICIZED CONVERSATION AT
TIMES.
ONE THING WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN,
AND I THINK THAT YOUR LAST
GUEST, THE FORMER D.C. POLICE
DETECTIVE SAID IT EARLIER.
THERE ARE TOO MANY GUNS ON THE
STREETS.
THIS IS NOT A STATEMENT ABOUT
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
IT'S JUST A STATEMENT THAT TOO
MANY OF THE WRONG PEOPLE HAVE
GUNS IN THEIR HANDS AND HOW ARE
HOMELESS PEOPLE AND OTHERS
GETTING GUNS IN THEIR HANDS WHEN
THEY CAN'T FEED OR SUPPORT
THEMSELVES.
SOMEHOW OR ANOTHER CAN FIND THE
MONEY TO BUY A GUN?
AGAIN WE NEED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF ALL OF THIS.
THERE IS A LOT OF HEART FELT
CONDOLENCES AND OTHER THINGS
GOING OUT TO THESE FAMILIES IN
THIS COMMUNITY.
I CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
INTERRUPT THAT THOSE IN PUBLIC
LIFE SHOULDN'T SHIRK THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE NEED HAVE THESE HARD,
UNCOMFORTABLE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO TO PREVENT
THESE KINDS OF THINGS FROM
HAPPENING GOING FORWARD.
>> Bret: MOLLIE?
>> I DO THINK AT TIMES LIKE THIS
PEOPLE DO TAKE COMFORT IN
TALKING ABOUT POLITICAL ANSWERS
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THIS
SCHOOL AND SO MANY OTHER MASS
SHOOTINGS.
AND THAT'S FINE.
I MEAN, RESTORING PEACE AND
ORDER TO OUR SOCIETY, IT IS A
POLITICAL QUESTION AND IT DOES
NEED TO BE DEBATED.
IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT THIS IS EVIL
AND THAT THERE ARE THINGS BEYOND
POLITICS THAT WE NEED TO DO.
WE JUST SEEM TO BE A COMPLETELY
BROKEN COUNTRY THAT DOES NOT
LOVE ONE ANOTHER.
THE PERSON WHO COMMITTED THIS
HORRIBLE ACT IS RESPONSIBLE
ALONE FOR WHAT HAPPENED.
BUT THERE ARE BIGGER ISSUES IN
PLAY ABOUT HOW WE TREAT ONE
ANOTHER.
THE LOVE WE SHOW, WHETHER WE
VALUE HUMAN LIFE AND THIS IS
SOMETHING POLITICAL BUT IT'S
ALSO SOMETHING MUCH MORE THAN
POLITICAL.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY SHOULD
THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN THEIR
LIVES, LOVE ONE ANOTHER.
THINK ABOUT HOW TO SHOW LOVE TO
PEOPLE THAT YOU MAYBE DON'T
NORMALLY SHOW LOVE TO TO ADDRESS
THE BROKENNESS AND FALLENNESS
AND TO PRAY FOR RELIEF FROM THIS
IT THAT IS BESIEGING US
THROUGHOUT THE LAND.
IN THIS THE SECOND MASS SHOOTING
IN 10 DAYS.
UNTENABLE WHAT WE HAVE HERE.
POLITICS IS AN APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING MUCH
DEEPER.
THERE IS A MORAL ROT GOING ON
THAT WE ALL NEED TO DIG IN AND
TRY TO ADDRESS.